all right very happy to bring on our our
next guest today tomorrow I think we
actually have Paul Joseph Watson on the
show or Thursday I I lose track of the
days it's tough uh we're gonna have
Thomas soul on the show soon the man is
not not feeling particularly good ever
next guest so I think we've written
about him a lot of credit column you can
follow him on YouTube I think if you
just search his name
avi Yemeni you can follow him on Twitter
at Ozzie avi I keep mispronouncing the
name because it's these are not words
he's an Australian Australian Jewish
reporter who recently did in does
YouTube videos I want to use the word
reporter because it's almost an insult
now right but recently did a show with
Jim Jefferies and Comedy Central and
then he we found out afterward that he
was recording Jim Jefferies with a
hidden camera and it's broken or lost
the meet brilliant just yeah just
brilliantly done by him Abby how are you
sure thank you for being here I'm good
thanks Adam you guys well no this is
you've always had a big presence online
on YouTube and you've definitely though
kind of broken through and exploded with
this recent story what is the real aim
for people first I guess who don't
exactly know what the timeline is you
were on a show Jim Jefferies show so
they called me actually a few months ago
and they asked me if I'll take part it
was in December and they asked me if I
would take part in a show with Jim
Jefferies discussing immigration
discussing the u.s. border war they were
in Australia at the time doing a tour
both in Melbourne and Sydney and I said
to him listen
in principle I would do this show in two
on two conditions
you don't have any narrow Nazis white
supremacy anyone like that on it with me
and you and you don't chop and change my
answers you know I'm pretty proud and
I'm pretty confident in what I have to
say if you're willing to keep my answers
as whole I'm happy to go on it the third
one was a technical issue I wasn't
actually in the country at the time I
said you'll have to wait till I'm I'm
back in Australia and they said to me
yep no worries you're back in January
they'll fly me to Singapore to do it
sounds to me like we have a diva on our
hands don't put me next to Nazis and
don't take me out of context who do you
think
the queen bee asking for blue M&Ms next
all right so spoiler alert for people
who don't know they did almost one could
argue the exact opposite of that so yeah
I have some clips we've taken from
YouTube channel please everyone again
search avi I want to make sure I get
this right avi Yemeni on you just search
and you'll find him
here is a clip that shows people who
have not been following it yet go watch
the whole video what the interview
showed on on air on Comedy Central
versus what actually happened I think we
should allow the African Fonda game what
about the black South Africans I'll take
that isn't what gives anyone the right
to tell anyone where they can and can't
live when you import this culture what
do you thinks gonna happen Australia's
gonna end up the same pole that they
came from that they were escaping see
what I really said what gives anyone the
right to tell anyone where they can and
can't place in society well this is a
utopia where we all just desire on a
level like we're inside a I'm a dreamer
I mean I think the most most people most
sensible people would agree with you in
theory yeah
but in practice it's not those get human
nature it just doesn't work again
everyone can go and watch the whole
video I strongly encourage them to watch
not only the whole video but you've
released a series of videos here it's
almost like Andrew Breitbart drip drip
drip so people as it unfolds it gets
worse and worse first off why did you
film this going in did you expect
obviously you expect this to happen
because you named your terms but you
probably expected them to still violate
it it seems well yeah I've been doing
you know in Australia I've been doing
this for a while now I used to James
then over the last few years I've sort
of naturally progressed into what I'm
doing now and I've noticed over time
just being taken out of context and
keeps sort of repeating itself
it's a singham line me up with people
that don't want to be associated with
ironically people usually hate me yeah
and what I stand for not seizing that
huge fan of Australian Jews typically no
so I just my dad told me to film it and
I thought how will you do it thinking
you know what I the way I'm gonna get it
you know it's a win-win-win for me
because I'm going to go to Singapore I'm
either either they're going and I'll
give him the benefit of the doubt either
they going to cut something up that I'll
be proud to put out myself or they'll
see me putting down these cameras and
they'll pick a fight with me saying what
are you doing I say I don't trust you so
and I've said that from the beginning
and they'll kick me out and I'll have
that on film or what happened was on
they were just so self-absorbed when I
walked in there no one noticed me
putting two phones down like a kite in a
coffee cup or something no they were
literally Truffaut and just went one is
blurry one isn't and always nervous one
was going to cut and it did play out
like that and and I laid it on a couch
[Laughter]
Wow
first up before we get into what your
actual views are and how egregious of a
synthesis from media standing what are
the I don't know what it's like over
there in Australia or Singapore do you
know what the the consent laws are as
far as filming were you worried about
that this wasn't because you know I went
into it I tend to go into these things
not thinking about the the legalities
issue yeah
Singapore Singapore does have pretty
strict rules from looking at it now I
think he's broken of Blades they
essentially have blasphemy laws a lot of
the stuff he said about Islam could
could send him to prison in Singapore
not me son I'm not through worried well
and that's why we have a clip of that in
a second because he was going to draw
Mohammed and he actually would say and
by the way I have no problem with you
I've we've Bob Ross came to Mohammed on
the show that being said he was far more
offensive to Muslims than anything that
you said and so I think the double
standard there is important but um
here's one thing this is what this
roundup and I think John they were
talking with us before to me if he
really dislikes your views if your views
are that heinous they're that evil they
don't need to doctor it you know in
other words the Westboro Baptist Church
they send out faxes every single day
they have like 14 members and two of
them have flippers they're inbred right
but the media can't get enough of them
because it is roll a camera on them and
they let them say their stuff they don't
need to edit out of context in this case
clearly what you were saying wasn't
offensive enough to make the cut so they
had to completely change answers to
different questions let me ask you
really quick for people who don't
necessarily follow you as closely yet
what are your views in your own words
regarding Islam immigration kind of
borders the topics that he was trying to
discuss is on for example I often and
through that interview I said it
numerous times and I told him and I
corrected him to stop conflating the
issues you have Islam and you have
Muslims they are separate things one's
an ideology that I'm I think needs to be
criticized and needs to be judged and
the other is a people that you cannot
pick on as a minority when it comes to
borders I believe you know open borders
don't seem to work for anybody and well
I'll get shotgun no but you're a Jew
Harvey how can you say that after the
Holocaust or not okay well my family it
was actually from Yemen as well you know
one half of my family's from Yemen they
kind of ran away from the Arabs in 48
you know so and what was the third I
think I think was immigration Islam and
borders that was it no I think you
covered all of it immigration in general
borders yeah I mean you're a Jew and so
obviously Israel you know walls tend to
play a big part it's almost a central
part to the Jewish faith
how could you support walls you're a Jew
they would be they would be pro wall
yeah yeah yeah this is Gerald so I I
agree with you completely on Islam right
you definitely have to to make sure that
you separate the two people but why why
do you feel like this is the one
religion in the world no matter what you
do no matter how many times you end up
on the news screaming yelling cutting
blowing up shooting no matter what you
do you're still a protected class
whereas Christian
we can come out and say hey we're really
not pro-abortion guys and all of a
sudden we're labeled as the worst and
most evil people maybe maybe next to a
Jews for some reason you guys for some
reason they keep going after you and us
it's the two of us and that's it it's
because the Jews have been fighting
Sneaky's well there is an unholy
alliance at the moment and I see it on
the front lawn when I got it you can see
some of my earlier youtube stuff I've
gone to many rallies to confront some of
these you know leftist groups that align
themselves literally with jihadis but
I'm standing there at one of these
rallies and you can see it on your chest
anything and you've got three guys with
the Hezbollah flag waving it and this
leftist transgender whatever I just said
you know each to their own whatever but
I'm just looking at him whatever yeah
doesn't make you realize they hate me a
lot and they hate me a lot they do they
will kill but will kill me the moment
they get a chance it's in their charter
you know you're first you're coming off
that building before me you're just a
useful idiot and you know I think I
think it's a number of things it's you
know they're very good they've had many
years applying victim and they had the
numbers I think Jews have always lacked
three things is numbers and
unfortunately courage like my community
has always thought standing back in you
know appeasing whoever the threat has
been works and historically it's never
worked okay you know look at World War
two how'd that turn out first I think
for us but you know the establishment
Jewish community they don't like me very
much
but those within my community we live in
the real world they loved me before
action I want to move on and get to
count of white supremacy because I tried
to falsely label you with that I don't
wanna say falsely I want to let you
speak for yourself maybe maybe you're
one of those Jewish white supremacist I
have no idea but I do want to show the
Clipper do we have it of Jim Jefferies
and what he did off air with Islam and
then we can follow through on that train
of thought
I think that wearing a burka is stupid
and demeaning and always think Islam
Islam or finger he's not a genie if you
think are sneaky yeah
probably fun dangerous thing I hate a
baby
be sure that you did like a buddy goes
one by you would have all right so let
me ask you this here's my question yeah
then he goes on to assert drawing maja
again I love a problem with it
necessarily I was I die I don't have a
problem with then I make that clear in
the video look I don't have a problem my
problem is when you change around and
chop me up and and toilet me right then
I'm the one that somehow radicalize this
nutjob white supremacist to kill fifty
innocent people why well that's that's a
question so do you think this whole kind
of war woke persona with Jim Jeffries is
is just to appease the comedy central de
Viacom gods because at one point however
people used to say this by Jim Jeffries
did say Jim Jeffries is really
politically incorrect that's like no Jim
Jeffries is just a lazy angry comedian
who uses the c-word a lot you know he
never actually touched Andre we always
tiptoes around the actually sensitive
issues do you think it's an act the
whole world yeah absolutely I think he's
playing to his his audience but what's
interesting is that Jim Jeffries made it
in America in fact you can argue he made
it when he knew that all gun thing in
Australia nobody cared because like he
said he literally just drops the see
gone every two minute and which were
used to talking like that so it's not
it's not that funny
right but in America and I think you
guys fall for that and I'm thinking I'm
hoping now that after we get off here
I've got a job at Comedy Central I doubt
it yeah I doubt it I mean you have
enough vowels in your last name but you
know unfortunately they're not really
the observant Jews they just like bagels
you know they're secularists and are in
our Jewish Hollywood here so okay first
let me just kind of pivot here are you a
white supremacist I got to get these out
here so that I'm being balanced no white
supremacist I'm trying not to laugh do
you have anyone like to back this up how
can
prove to me that you are not a white
supremacist are you wearing are you
wearing a little hat
I'm not wearing today I hardly do so I
do wear the keeper
you know I come from an ultra-orthodox
family I'm I'm one of 17 kids I'm the
middle child of 17 kids that is my claim
to fame I've got middle child syndrome -
I'm 17
but I wear that keep aunt today not
because I believe in God I have my own
problems with God and faith and whatever
I wear in situations where I believe
that I'm gonna get called a Nazi or
they're gonna do something like they did
there and you will not believe how many
times I have walked into different
events there was one with Milo here in
Melbourne where I just walked into this
crowd and suddenly you have chanting by
huge groups of leftists and again jihad
ease-of-use a Nazi are these enough and
I'm wearing a kippah on my head right
what they do with it if they do it with
Ben Shapiro I mean you haven't really
got a shot because it's a sleeper cell
for the Nazis hard yeah see if we were
any other interviewing chair right there
that's the clip that's the part nine
Shapiro is an odd you know I used to
watch your wings
sorry hopper this is just a nightmare
interview I'm sorry you know funny
Leggett's it'll get more viewers than
Jim Jeffries who would have thought have
you had experiences like this before
with with media interviews and pretty
cuz I was at Fox News for four and a
half years at CNN HLN BBC Sky News all
the stuff and I had these experiences so
often where I mainly just stopped
appearing on on media I particularly
made it even media that agreed with me
I'll actually only do media of opposing
viewpoints and I'll usually ask for the
full tape but it haven't done in a while
have you run into this before is that
why you were tactically and it's you
know I've never had a problem doing
things alive yeah I might fumble my
words or whatever and come off a little
bit stupid at some points especially
after a big night out but I was always
you know I was always able to get I was
ever calls always confident that my
words we're not going to be distorted
right
a few times I've had different
experiences on almost every single other
news network here where they just do cut
you up and you know they'll say and and
it's it's the argument that they have to
cut inductive timing is fine and I agree
with that I do a lot of editing but my
problem is when they cut it up and then
mix and match you know they'll ask you
one question and then either port get
you pulling some weird facial expression
or saying something just silly that's
where that's where I've had the problem
time and time again and that's why now I
don't think anyone is going to employ me
for many so the the people in the
audience so if we were to walk out in
that audience and find maybe the most
logical person hinting that you were
Anansi if that's possible to exist what
do you think that they would use
evidence what do you think that they
would say it's actually interesting
because in the beginning in Australia
let's just put it out there because they
hate fascism there's so they had this
article and it's one it's a top article
that you find if you look for me and and
useful title used to be um the said six
cons IV was a anoxia time and then they
realize how silly it sounded that they
changed it to now it's the seven-time RV
has consorted with Nazis right and
that's what these this this is what all
these different leftist groups
especially the non the majority of
Martin Jewish but they just refer to
that they go oh yeah yeah obviously
you're not a Nazi even though just 30
seconds ago you were chanting I am right
but obviously not you
just couldn't sort with them you allow
them to thrive and it's like you know
everybody on that list that they that
they actually put their hates me right
don't like them they've captured like me
at one event where and some dude who I
didn't know walked up to shake my hand
and I'm just not a very pleasant
somebody walks if I knew he was a Nazi
at the time or in neon and so it
obviously wouldn't shake I know they
don't all look like Eddie furlong in
American History X I don't have the next
act anymore sometimes it's hard they've
done a rebranding listen I've had this
where people accuse me being a Nazi and
then a famous neo-nazi website of course
once they found out I supported Israel's
right to exist started doing these false
memes and they put fake swastika tattoos
on my chest on my neck like fake photo
shops with quotes that said you know
hang the Jews gasps the N words all
those kinds of these horrible things and
we sent him to Twitter and said these
are fake tweets that I've never tweeted
out yes no it's not a violation of our
policies so Nazis realize they could do
more damage by claiming people as their
own because they don't like Jews so
they'll actually do that sometimes
they're actually sort of false flag
attacks I have this time right now so
following the gyms everything I've been
kicked off Facebook again but now if you
look up my name any pages they're all
fake pages in my name that do similar
things right so if you're going and I've
reported but they those don't breach any
of their - no they don't you know that's
the pesky community standards right
things with a legal precedent like libel
and slander like no we're more offended
that you know you made a transgender men
go home was that male to female or
female in the mirror like you know let's
just go with pansexual we don't really
want to go with the drop-down menu today
and have to do a whole redesign yeah
this is it really is a remarkable time
that we're living in where they just
throw around this this moniker not see
all of the time let me what what's
what's the fallout first off I think Sam
Robertson Jim Norton we're talking with
us I said could you imagine if a
conservative show had done this and they
actually said no I mean if it flower was
crowded they mentioned this show was
very kind of them saying they edited
someone out of context we have had far
left people on the show yeah you will
never find someone on this show who will
say that we've edited them out of
context or screwed up the time I think
we've had two guests we've
edited one was because the guests
requested afterward it was something was
a liability and one was a guy who
basically fell asleep and was so boring
or like we just can't - we never do that
that in it's by design this is and this
is also an entertainment show so I
understand like you said you have to
edit for time especially if it's a
comedy show but when I watched this
segment by the way it wasn't really
designed for comedy for Laughs it was
much more so designer on making a
political statement where's Jon Stewart
we'll go for some funny first often
absolutely and that's the thing the
argument that it's just a comedy showing
you know are you telling me that he went
into that to make a whole joke about the
Christ Church Massacre because that's
almost worse right now yeah and it's it
obviously wasn't a comedy thing it was
obviously bit designed to you know in
invoke people's well what so what's the
joke it's like ah ah bees are not see
he's really not that's not the joke now
if he if he thought your views were
crazy for example let's say yeah it's a
really radical view on it on immigration
right like to me I don't know I'm trying
to think of an example like I don't know
no borders open borders you know radical
view let's say you had a view like that
and he would just wanted to showcase it
hey this is a joke because what he's
saying is crazy but you're not going in
for comedy if you're saying he's a Nazi
and he's not that's not a joke that's
just a lot if you watch it he's angle is
literally gone the joke was you see the
one thing that can unite Jews and Nazis
today is that their joint hype from
Muslims that's that was literally what
he said in there
yeah we're just factually wrong
disgraceful and to do it after Christ
Church is just offensive and unless
someone that's easily offended right but
if I did I'm just so grateful that I
took those cat look I I just imagine
today if I'd done that interview and let
that end and not had my own footage to
Kony he would have never been able to
clear your name I had that happen before
I had happened where articles in
Washington Post Young Turks would do
videos about and I back then I didn't
have a platform I didn't have the
forethought so I was never able to clear
my name it's an amazing time now where
you can't
you know I said under the tutelage of
Andrew Breitbart and I think one of the
perfect examples he sat down with I
think was Martin Bashir all that guy's a
smug prick anyway I mean he is the
different like you look I'm smug
talentless a bag of pricks in the
dictionaries gotten Martin Bashir's face
next was my shears sitting there
interviewing Andrew Breitbart they
always try to accuse him of being a Nazi
by the way he was part Jewish remember
Martin Bashir's interviewing him asking
about his views views on race he goes
you know what about this any old racist
and he just said name me can you name me
one thing one thing that I've said that
is racist and then Martin Bashir pivots
to what's your relationship like with
alcohol and Andrew Breitbart just said
why are you asking me this why are you
asking me this question
and I remember the leftist media this is
back before Breitbart was a thing this
is back before this show was really a
thing the media tried to say Andrew
Breitbart becomes unhinged at Martin
Bashir he said what's your relationship
with alcoholism why are you asking me
this and they try to act like it was
crazy and I when I saw that happen more
people went and watched the clip on
YouTube and I saw the comments go I
don't know who this Andrew Breitbart guy
is but he totally owned this Martin
Bashir and I feel like that was a
turning point because now there's more
sunlight and at one point no one would
have heard your side sorry are you at
least grateful for that I know this has
been an ordeal but man that's a blessing
I I'm I am and I said in the beginning I
sat on that footage because I also was
gonna give him the benefit of death I
could have made a media either way right
but we had an agreement and I was like
maybe because even after i sat with him
I thought you know he's alright like
he's actually alright and he's kind of
reasonable had some wacky ideas but he's
okay and when I saw it I was actually I
was at a pouring thing the other night a
Purim event and some like real religious
Jew turns to me go so I saw you last
night on Jim Jefferies show oh he
totally butchered you he slaughtered you
I'm like I didn't even know who that
yeah and then I come huh you know
pouring I was like right and I watched
it and then I should have put my phone
down but then I just went where are you
signifying that Purim is poram as a real
party is obvious I see a magenta yeah
so you're going basically I looked like
you now see our equivalent I guess we
don't really have it like but like
Thanksgiving it's not that crazy so I
picked your broom is like a family
gathering not really a big party but
okay it'd be fun one pouring back a lot
of funny money yeah when he has a few
bugs I see my YouTube comments people
say that I wear to keep a better people
I'd seen and watch the footage their
employment I just couldn't believe the
level of hack job they did to me and the
you know I was expecting it to a level
but then to Thome with Christ Church I
just always shock
yeah and this this should it be noted
for people who don't know this interview
was taped long before the Christ Church
shooting long and they aired it
afterwards and they connected it
retroactively Lee which by the way again
there's forgiveness there in media where
sometimes things just air late of course
and you go oh now it's more timely but
they directly tried to tie this to press
really said let's look at the people who
radicalized him yeah and then they had
like a couple of the Nazis and ones that
weren't supposed to be on it and then
that made well here's something
interesting to me too because you
mentioned sort of this this leftist
coalition between Muslims and the LGBTQ
at least in the United States no Rasheed
slave and all this stuff but
historically if you look at this
the Nazis actually allied themselves
more with the Muslim world historically
if you look at Nazis have a much greater
use for Islam and they do the Jews in
any capacity absolutely look at the what
we see the movie of Jerusalem and Hitler
will literally mint right I also believe
if you look at the ideologies there are
a lot of similarities there where it
does align yeah yeah it's an it's a it's
also it's a political prescription in
ideology that's the thing with Islam
it's very different from most religions
people don't understand it is a
political prescription it outlines how
you're supposed to also run assisting in
government yeah
and that's the part that you are made
probably and majority people that are
that have an issue with it don't have an
issue with that aspect of all these um
it's more the political right and you
know the whole jihadi side
yeah that's kind of an issue for me you
know once people start blowing people up
I go hold on a second yeah way I think
we crossed some line this is another
thing that I pointed out in the show in
the foot in the actual thing I said
listen I don't have a problem I come
from you what you can argue is a
fundamentalist religion religious sect I
know what fundamental fundamentalism in
in religion kind of does to people
right I think you're like I'm good
friends with the chief rabbi of astray
I always tell him either I think you
guys are all nuts you all believe in
fairy tales but I don't care doesn't
bother me I enjoy having a drink with
you guys I enjoy talking you know
discussing issues whatever my problem is
when your ideas and your religion or
your God is preaching to you to hurt me
or kill me no that's where like I kind
of draw the line yeah I even said that
when people try to paint we to go back
to the Westboro Baptist Church and like
they're not really Christians are 14
members they're not aligned with any
mainstream Christian denomination but
even then is for I go hey law second
they're not Christians they're jerks but
you know a guy has a sign that says God
hates [ __ ] I go he is the right to do
that I think he's a jerk but it doesn't
really he's not hurting anybody
physically and I understand if people
want to get into specifics as far as
libel laws if they claim something about
somebody but even then there are some
crazy religions out there where I go
everything they think is wrong I don't
care it's when you physically commit
acts of violence and do so consistently
on a global scale in name of religion
and also when when it consistently
inciting it yes
you know you'll pick me on Facebook for
offending somebody's hurting somebody's
feelings but every Friday in any kind of
religious structure you can hear
incitement against me yeah we're seeing
a waitress in a Farrakhan sermon any
Farrakhan sermon on stage I'm like how
is this thank you this is unbelievable
so yeah one of the things I want to
bring up that it's really ironic or
interesting I'm not sure which I think
Courtney's gonna get on to me
for saying ironic in the wrong place
probably it's that they are saying that
you're a Nazi and they're doing
something that Nazis have done they're
doing something that people in the
united states did with kind of the Red
Scare with communists they basically
just throw everything you say under this
umbrella term so that nobody will
believe you because of that one thing
that's exactly what the Nazis did to
discredit Jews right that was all the
propaganda that's exactly what some
politicians the United States did to
credit somebody who was a communist
right that lived in the United States
it's it's so strange and I guess you're
now this cautionary tale if you're gonna
do an interview with somebody make sure
you get the footage right like that's
that's a really difficult thing to do
but you have to fight that because right
now we live in a society where you can
just throw somebody into the bus by
saying Nazi just like Ben Shapiro got
done by the Economist all right there's
like are you serious yeah right now now
everybody's a good point though that
they use that same kind of propaganda
against the Jews the Nazis use it
against and now they're using it
painting everyone as a Nazi yeah they
showed they showed movie theater footage
of rats running and talking about Jews
right right before movies they did the
same thing with Japan showing them as
these hulking beasts coming to like pull
your skull out of your head like is
there a question coming so the question
is how up short of just asking for this
footage and short of having the
platforms like this how do you get how
do you get the message out to people I
mean because it's got to be very
frustrating you're right in the middle
of it it's a good question stop with the
question yeah all right necessarily have
your platform well I didn't always have
my platform that's it seem like you know
I think today people are looking for the
truth and that's why that's why now when
I first lost my first facebook page with
200,000 followers it killed me I was
gutted because this is the only platform
I used and I thought that's the end of
me having a platform and then I just
open different accounts on all the other
platforms and I realize that people are
just looking for the truth today there
is so much rubbish out there and there's
so much shoved down everybody's throat
through the mainstream media especially
that people are looking for the truth so
if you just keep producing the truth and
right now like I know my phone's is
probably not gonna cut it anymore so I'm
going to invest
a little spy camera because I don't
think anybody's not going to I'm gonna
take my phone duct tape to your chest
what's that nothing
that's my new pacemaker religious symbol
I need uranium to keep my heart beating
properly my name is now Stark please
just continue with your day no I think
you're right and I didn't always have
this platform and people are I notice a
big shift because I was public enemy
number one on YouTube for a long time
because there was no one else there back
in 2008-2009 no one and now there is
more of a coalition you have a coalition
by the way of people people like serious
libertarian libertarians then you have
traditional conservatives and you do
have some alt-right people in there with
whom I would disagree but you do have a
much broader coalition than just the far
far radical left which by the way I feel
confident saying is all of mainstream
media yeah it really is that they're all
radical yeah look at what you get fries
did that's radical to me I questioned
you before we go
what's the fallout bin if I understand
this correctly didn't he disable
Instagram comments it's been
unbelievable I thought it was gonna
force him to actually respond or Comedy
Central to make some sort of statement
and all that's happened is that the
Chinese tactic of ignoring and you can
understand if you look at Twitter like
just Jim Jeffrey comments in the last
week tweets have literally been
consistent almost every minute for the
last week and all they've done is
they're banning anyone and you can look
on my Twitter you can see like I'm put a
tweet up there saying if you've been
banned just share a screenshot you see
hundreds upon hundreds of screenshot so
people have been banned and then even
shared what they've said yeah and
there's nothing there's nothing really
contemplate nothing bad to say man are
you going to just stand up and own what
you did or apologize nothing so their
tactic is to ignore they think it's
gonna go away and that this is where
they should have spoke to my mum I don't
know that I am persistent and I'm good
until I get a response until they
actually stand up and face the music and
respond to what they've done because
what they do
was wrong on any left unaccounted from
the left the right I don't care who you
are what they did and I'm not even
talking about his comments at the end
there which you know what like I'd like
you in this in the Skype comedy adding a
problem with it but I personally
probably wouldn't say happy things he
said but unduly about the actual editing
the ethics of that what they did there
to try ruined me you know that is wrong
to anyone and that's what they've gotta
just face but like I say good luck
talking to kid try ignoring because it
only in fact it's it's only working to
my benefit I think if they would have
just said something the first day it
probably would have just gone away
that's very interesting ironically their
content is still up there Facebook knows
it's fake use Facebook you know it's
defamatory and on my one got deleted on
Facebook it's very interesting I'm not
familiar with the entirety of this case
and we have people looking into it
that's uh that's Jack that's Jack Dorsey
for a little bit eject I've heard rumors
circulating that you might be taking
legal action there might be some
recourse here can you let people know
about that or where to go and follow us
and I'm coming on YouTube he's probably
new to Twitter Instagram I don't know
you know every day gets them my good
friend Tommy Robinson's being basically
banned from I know you had him on a
couple weeks it has been banned from
YouTube as well so to be honest the only
platform I know that that's trustworthy
for us to put out our content is TR news
ok that's where we're gonna run
everything through but for now YouTube
Twitter will go I'm coming to the States
yeah we've got a bit of a tour it's
gonna be quick sharp there's some good
fun in there and including what what
you're saying we'll announce properly
when we're there
it's TR TR news T and by the way you
were talking about this before the break
you like I hope I hope they'll let me in
the States
it's not your country you need to
understand here they don't ban you like
I can't go back to Canada to perform I'm
afraid of that you don't need to be
afraid United States they're not gonna
they're not gonna kick you out for
saying something offensive they don't
care because I just questioned because
obviously Connie
seneschal knows I'm coming yeah I
haven't hidden that fact I've been
pushing this idea I'm calling up my
American tour against the to fight bike
news so I want to see how far Comedy
Central is gonna push it because if I
get to because I've been to America a
number of times I've never had a problem
so if I get there and I'm not let in we
know exactly what it is enemies behind I
don't think that's gonna happen I mean
there's a you might you might have
problems with your visa as far as
earning here but you can still come here
and visit whereas not for me I wouldn't
be able to go to certain areas of you
this is probably the first time that Jew
is saying this live on air I am coming
to America not to earn a dollar list you
keep running your banks is that included
well then all right
maybe a few dollars just in pocket
change here yeah I know it's almost like
Jim Jefferies I usually I don't get the
Jim Jefferies thing I don't get the
tremor Noah thing I always thought Jon
Stewart was funny I do think John Oliver
is funny I I disagree I think he's funny
I've never gotten the Jim Jefferies
thing the John Hall thing I think a big
putts are the Trevor Noah thing Trevor
Noah is worse than Jim Jefferies Jim
Jefferies has at least produced a couple
of smirks when I watch them Trevor Noah
makes me angry like I would rather be
watching hardcore pornography with my
mother and have to sit through Trevor
Noah it's that uncomfortable what's that
on flowers I can't believe that made air
alright TR dot news and that's where
people can follow you're American tours
you come out here and if there are any
legal issues there get arrested I keep
it tight lift but I do hope you do
something there and hopefully find
yourself a good good Jewish American
lawyer not not name to have a naughty
yeah that's what you got caught you
don't hire an Italian lawyer alright
thank you so much avi we appreciate your
brother we appreciate you helping the
helping to shine a light on this thank
you
hey there if you like this video this is
the part where I would usually tell you
to subscribe but I can't do it anymore
I'm going to tell you to subscribe and
then YouTube is going to decide that we
can't reach you even though you
subscribe to this channel and then I'll
say hit the
Bell and then the notification Bell
won't even be there anymore I don't know
what to say more than likely you'll find
my face in a milk carton but do what you
can to stop it it's just that it's just
it probably won't do much